هنذهب لان صباح العربيه تابع معكم اجواء
المباراه من الرباط هذه المره ما عدا
الزبير متابعه
[موسيقى]
ليله مغربيه مفتوحه على الفرح
المنتخب المغربي يتاهل لاول مره في مباراه
تاريخيه اخرى يهزم المنتخب البرتغالي
ويتاهل الى دور النصف اسود الاطلس يلعبون
المربع الذهبي في نهايتك كاس العالم في
قطر 2022
تعليق على فوز المغرب
ايه ده سامح العرب والمنتخب الوطني
قدام دول العربيه كامله
اول مره في التاريخ يتاهل فريق عربي وفريق
افريقي اول مره في تاريخ كره القدم اوه
وكشكرون
مجهودات رونالدو
ما شاء الله عليهم ما شاء الله حمرنه وجنى
رايك في المنتخب المغربي
كبير تبارك الله عليه واللي عنده المغرب
بكار و رونالدو
[موسيقى]
لو كنت من اول يوم مسيره موفقه ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله نديو الكاس علاش لا
المنتخب
المغرب
[تصفيق]